我跟你说，
一个人的经济指标就是一个人的本质，
你说过天了，
他40岁了，
他又吵，
为啥？
我觉得到了人生的转折点的，
我92年的，
我对象八七年的，
我俩异定在扯县城，
自己买房买车，
月入两个左右，
他是差不多一万，
但是是那种传统行业，
但没有什么存款，
我们俩父母都给不了帮助，
现在这个阶段我们俩谈了两年了，
觉得是埃结婚升子了，
父母觉得我俩年纪也大了，
综合考虑，
我觉得不适合结婚。
他八七年快40了，
也没有存款，
有一定存款，
快40了，
他有啥，
性格挺好的，
属于那种很居家的那种，
我问他有啥，
他有房吗？
他有车吗？
他有正经工作吗？
有正经工作月收入一万五左右，
月收入一万五都没啥存款，
他这些年他混啥了？
他说他以前花到前面的对象了，
前面的对象吃肉你来啃不够差不，
嗯嗯，
有个二三十个是吧，
那他除了说有二三十个存款之外呢，
他还有啥呀，
你那有没房备车，
父母又帮不上忙，
你他自己买的有房有车全款，
你俩异义，
所以说我现在让他去考一个证啊，
如果是未来想到我们小县城发展的话，
我是建议他先做自己的身材管理嘛，
身体养好再去考个证，
妹妹啊和二。
天的啊，
我得我给你捋一捋啊，
这男的快40岁了，
眼纪的就40岁了，
没房没车，
也没有什么存款，
然后父母就帮不上忙，
完了之后他还胖，
还身体不咋地，
完了他跟你还不在一个地方，
你就跟我说他有什么过人之处呢，
你要嫁给他呢？
我一共就谈了两段，
前面一段相对比较深，
就很难总是一段感情嘛，
我个人是这么，
可自身很少有那种感情上面的那种相处，
你现在这个人生啊，
其实挺轻松的，
节业的工作，
为了房这个也成，
女生也很轻松的，
你不能给自己找一个难度基数太高的这样一个对象，
因为父母在催，
说自己很清楚，
觉得不应该去走进下一段关系，
而且走进了也生活也会比较难一点，
也跟他说的很辛楚了，
他也是认可的，
如果说我们俩去结婚再生子，
去买一个小孩的话，
压力会比较大，
担心的就把你当个小姐妹来看的话，
我觉得你这个结婚不如不结，
因为你结婚会降低你的生活质量，
你结婚会增加你的社会复杂程度，
会增加你的麻烦，
但是我觉得我这个年龄也到了，
也该结婚生子的，
在父母年龄，
你该结婚，
你就在你们小县城找嘛，
你找一个父母有退休金的嘛，
能够帮衬到一点点的嘛，
你找一个说你年龄相当的嘛，
也是。
这92年的吗？
你该找吗？
找不着，
我这种性格有点难，
你找不着还不如单身，
你要找一个，
第一，
快40岁了，
第二，
父母帮不上任何忙，
第三没房没车，
第4也几乎没有什么存款，
第5跟你还不在一个地方，
你找这么一个人的话，
你还不如不找，
我相不清，
在小县城跟他出之前我确实相过，
但是市场什么出景啊，
异地啊，
什么样的都遇到，
我觉得太难弄，
我就不想象了，
你能花钱来问我了，
我要对得起你花的这个钱，
我要对得起我的良心和我的专业。
我现在的建议呢，
就是说你再观察观察，
再看一看，
你不要积极主动的去推动结婚这个事儿，
你看她能拿出什么诚意，
她愿不愿意为你付出什么，
她愿不愿意来你这里，
第一做好避孕措施，
这是我给你的人生忠告，
不要轻易的怀孕生孩子，
第二，
就算要怀孕生孩子的话，
也要在一起生活一年之后再考虑这个事儿啊，
好不好？
要同时去接触其他的男生吗？
但真的在我心里面过不去，
我从我这个角度的话，
你这个对象真的不如没有在我们看大局，
他他本身也还行，
就是没有乱七八糟的关系，
性格也还可以，
也很菊花，
你说破天了，
他40岁了，
他要啥没啥，
我跟你说，
一个人的经济指标就是一个人的本质，
你说破。
天了，
他40岁了，
他要啥没啥告就这样啊，
咋一个人的亲气就是一个人的本质，
你说破天了，
他就是40岁了，
要啥没啥，
啥也没有，
而且他还跟你异地，
要身体还不咋地，
你听刚才那个妹妹的说法，
还要让她健身，
还要让她减肥，
还要让她注意身体，
还要啥啥没有，
我还帮不上忙，
你怎么搞？
记得点赞关注哦。